be specific not this average mediocre
generalist if you are a pizza lover and
you think about the great pizza places
in the United States none of them are
full-service restaurants with big menus
they make a thing and they make it the
best they can make it because it must be
done with care or it becomes mediocre we
have created an entire generation of
wandering generalities as ziggs would
say instead of meaningful specifics
and to be a meaningful specific you have
to say this is what I do you can say and
and and and because then you have an
excuse for everything being sort of
average if somebody is more focused than
you they're going to put in more Cycles
than you and they're going to learn more
than you and inevitably they're going to
become better than you when you have
enough competitors you want to be in and
of yourself the one and only version of
that the only way that's going to happen
is if I say no to all sorts of
attractive things